turning now to Syria where the Assad
regime is denying it is carrying out
mass killings and then burning the
bodies new satellite images appear to
show a crematorium next to a prison
north of Damascus the u.s. believes as
many as 50 prisoners are executed each
day
this comes as rebel fighters and
families evacuate Syrian cities as assad
forces retake more and more control Seth
Doane has the latest they don't use the
word surrender here but that's what it
is this morning after years of battling
Assad Syrian army opposition fighters
stood face-to-face with their sworn
enemies who ushered them onto buses
bound for a main opposition area in
Syria's north since Monday more than
2300 rebels and their families have left
the AL water district of Homs in a deal
that evacuates rebels and strengthens
Assad's hold on Syria's big cities some
carried weapons chickens or whatever
they had left in their own videos this
young man said we were forced out don't
think we left on her own will God
willing we shall come back the buses
pulled out under the watchful eye of
Assad but it's hardly an end to the
story Syria is a country with no
shortage of front lines and competing
interests Assad's forces continue to
pound rebel pockets in his own cities
and another group led by Kurds is taking
aim at the ISIS stronghold of Raqqa
preparing an assault us-led coalition
airstrikes are paving the way for that
advance Seth Doane Jones us on the phone
now from Homs in Syria a Seth so we just
want to ask about the evacuations that
are underway what does this latest
victory mean for the regime of Bashar
al-assad well it's symbolic it continues
to solidify this control over Syria's
main cities so we're seeing that take
place here in Homs we've also seen over
the weekend in the suburbs of Damascus
the center the center of Damascus these
relatively secure and decided certain is
in control he's not in control in some
of the suburbs but
kind of several pronged approach one of
the mystic pommel only rebels with
everything needed still missiles
airstrikes killing these these these
rebels but the other is this rebel
evacuation has been polished
humanitarian but many people say it's
really just a horse to displacement but
allowing these levels to leave as we
said in the piece they don't use the
word surrender but that's really that it
is and it's allowing its allowing Bashar
al-assad to have more control of these
cities which is a really small picture
so then what happens after these rebel
fighters and their families evacuate
don't they still remain targets
absolutely I think that's the big
question we asked the governor of Homs
about that he said okay they've all been
loaded onto this bus they're all going
to be bused mounted northern Syria what
is the government's plan then they're
all being moved with other rebel
stronghold really which I have a
hornet's nest of different rebel rapes
that don't all agree with each other so
what are you going to do once you get in
there and the governor of Homs devoxx
white said for now with the troops that
he added even continue to fight
terrorism now even you're eating to get
it or you know what I didn't get is
these guys if they're seen as opposing
the government could very well continue
to be a target just no longer in Homs
organized gets up and it corralled and
it's maybe a province up near Turkey
ACEF we have to ask you about the mass
killings I mean human rights groups have
been reporting that the regime's
atrocities throughout Syria's Civil War
what evidence support is the State
Department's claim that the government
the Syrian government is using a
crematorium to hide the evidence of
potential war crimes what we heard from
the W today is a categorical denial that
this exists at all they have said
thinking it's absolutely
fabrication is not true.really have been
trying to get our own interviews on the
subject invest for had not had anyone
featuring a high-ranking government
official on this issue but that is the
that is the official answer from the
government that they categorically
denied it then if you talk to a lot of
series we have to take some of the
military insulted his remember I'm in
I'm the guest of the government in in
the estrade stronghold but he had to in
popularity here he asked people and they
say well who else is there
what happens if this guy goes away they
don't know what the alternative is and I
keep hearing at least need the table
stronghold judge between election today
we vote for him again or he did vote for
him in support and real kind of general
mistrust distrust as you've ever seen is
an allegation he's coming from the left
yeah that's a real indication that you
know we certainly see one side of the
story here but there were many many
sides to this story and clearly he has
his supporters right absolutely
Seth Doane reporting from Homs in Syria
Seth thank you very much they say